Speaker 1: Donald Trump sort of newish
spokeswoman Liz Harrington appeared
yesterday on the water cooler on Real America's
Voice with this guy, David Brody. She was asked
to comment about Joe Biden's speech and
also about the upcoming midterms. And
this is a prototypical example. This is the
textbook example of a priori reasoning. Okay,
forget about everything I just said.
Just let's listen to the clip and then
I'll explain to you what I mean.
Speaker 3: Somehow he thinks he's
going to be this last minute savior
for his party at the last moment with
the midterms. Why is Biden doing this tonight?
Speaker 7: You know, that's a very good question,
because anyone who.
Speaker 1: Knows
it's not that great of a question.
Speaker 7: But is he's such a drag on
the Democrat Party and any chance they have,
which we know they don't come next Tuesday,
they don't have a chance unless they cheat. As
you documented very well, there's so many cases
already of just irregularities and misdeeds.
Speaker 1: That's not true.
Speaker 7: Evidence of the corruption in our
election process. And that's the only hope
that they have, because the fact is, Democrats do
not like democracy. They don't want the voters to
decide. They want to decide for the voters.
Speaker 1: That's not really the way
it went in 2020 as it was.
Speaker 7: And look at how
that has worked out. They're destroying the
country. They've destroyed our border. They've
destroyed the economy. They destroyed our energy
independence. All of these things that were so
hard fought by President Donald J. Trump to put
America first, they're destroying and the voters
know it and they know they're going to lose
come Election Day unless they do some of these
outrageous things that they did in 2020 and do
it on such a scale that we've never seen before,
because they're going to have to overcome really
this mammoth red wave that's coming. Yeah.
Speaker 1: This is red alert stuff, folks.
They're doing it again. They are doing the fascist
authoritarian thing. If they win, then they must
have cheated Democrats. That is a priori now,
a priori means reasoning which precedes from
a theoretical deduction rather than from
observations or experiences. So what does that
mean in this context? They're not observing actual
cheating or waiting until Election Day to see how
the election goes. And then if there really are
irregularities or cheating, then you go, Oh,
this is what happened. It's theoretical, it's
in advance. Absent any actual data or empirical
reality. If they win, they cheated regardless of
what we actually observe. And of course, they add
on to it another classic authoritarian wrinkle,
which is to claim you observed the thing anyway,
even though you didn't. Oh, there's already
irregularities. The irregularities we're seeing
now are, for example, armed individuals hanging
around Arizona, drop boxes, right wingers trying
to intimidate voters. The only irregularities
we're seeing are from people on Liz Harrington's
side. These folks are disgusting and they're
delusional, but they're dangerous. And we've
talked about all of the reasons why and it
should really scare the daylights out of all
of us, because what they tried to do in 2020,
they might get close enough in 2022 to then
really be able to do it in 2024. We'll have
all the results. But these folks will say it's
rigged if they don't win. And that's really scary.